[Music]  [Music]  you know Aretha without question you  know one of the greatest voices in music  ever Aretha Franklin the Queen of Soul  will be honored at the 2018 MTV Video  Music Awards we're definitely gonna  honor her we're talking about what that  is still I'm still working it through we  want to obviously it's Aretha Franklin  we want to get it right and honor her in  the best and biggest possible way  I mean she's performed on this stage  many times in her career in this room so  it's it's important  [Music]  Aretha died on August 16th after  battling pancreatic cancer just days  before the Big Show  BMA bosses tell ET they plan to pay  tribute to the iconic singer's legacy  it's pretty emotional we're definitely  trying to figure out how to put  something together that it feels right  and fitting and for scrambling but we're  focused on it without question  [Music]